I am inspector clip with the Portland
Gas Company and someone has reported a
leak a gas leak what are you doing this
is my son Todd
hi Oscar winner Marcia Gay Harden stars
as Margaret and Pitch Perfect Skyler
Aston stars as her son Todd a razor
sharp lawyer and former private
detective in the new CBS comedy so help
me Todd Jillian spoke with the stars of
the show to learn more
well I want to start by saying that I
think I have truly signed a petition to
bring Zoe's extraordinary playlist and
code black back because those were two
of my all-time favorite shows but I'm so
happy you guys found each other and now
we're excited for her so help me Todd so
Skyler I'll start with you what Drew you
to this role and how's it been so far
well it's been a blast um I love playing
a character that's unconventional and uh
uh has you know different Wild Card
tactics to what he does and being a
private investigator you don't always
have to do so by the book like my
high-powered attorney mother so it is um
it's it's a fortunate role to be able to
play that uh I also love the the
physical quirkiness that I get to bring
I know who's the murderer
um and uh and I do love to you know to
undo the shade of not only working with
her but um the the two-hander aspect the
dynamic is just delicious sorry work
from home if you hear my dogs barking
they want to be a part of this
everywhere we're all in this together
I'll come over to you what are you
excited for people to see I love when we
get to experience just a new show fresh
new cast there's a lot to look forward
to tonight
okay this is a fun show it's a dramedy
each night you get to have a case that
you follow and so that adds a little
mystery each night you're following the
progression of the family and how the
dysfunction of the family is helping is
for or against them and therein lies a
lot of the comedy for the two of us and
speaking of CVS now you guys are part of
this family we're talking about Survivor
before you started was that kind of the
ideal crossover if you guys could live
in any other show we were thinking how
amazing he would be on Survivor how
Margaret would be appalled by the bugs
and the things on survived but then she
would know old school things and he
would know you know the guys or anything
it would be fantastic and my
manipulation but also hot take I think
Margaret wins I think Todd thinks he's
got it all under control and he does
have the tactics and then you know he
gets voted off because he is a threat
then you have to learn what I've taught
you a little bit and your own skills and
I believe Margaret wins that episode
I support this Margaret I like this
sometimes it's the people you least
expect to surprise you the most lastly
Skyler I saw on Instagram wasn't
stalking but just all your stories you
were filming some stuff from the
trailers and you guys were filming I
think you said the seventh episode
getting into the Thanksgiving season so
what can we expect down the road any
teasers throughout the season
all I will tease you with is that there
is a little bit of evolution in the
family and
um it is very exciting and it all kind
of comes together in that Thanksgiving
episode we're so excited for the
premiere right here on CBS us tonight
for so health and Todd and Before I Let
You Go Skyler I'm a big Pitch Perfect
Fan so I need a little Breakfast Club
you know a little little pump in the air
before we go
[Applause]